[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing wrong
i've lost my influence maybe it's time i
retired the coat
you still have it some kids with a deer
rifle put two holes in the sleigh one in
me
all i have is a loathing for a world
that's forgotten
the united states military would like to
procure your services
this is a one-time deal gentlemen
how are you mike nicole and the kids are
well i hope
who are you
[Music]
what's the job i'd like you to kill
santa claus
i'm looking for the fat man you can't be
serious
this is what people actually think of me
christmas is a farce i am a joke
what's the purpose of your visit hunting
i'm gonna kill some things
there is a rising number of our youth
making poor decisions
what the big man's head severed heads
rot they mold they don't want his beard
i'm not shaving off a dead man's beard
your workers sure have healthy appetites
that's why elves live much longer than
humans and chris he knows the same
no it's a giving that keeps him young
i've come for your hand fat man
dashing through
[Music]
i think i got this job because i'm fat
and jolly
open side
oh come on you sleep the fat man's got
his eye on you
kids hey whoa oh that's donner lucky it
wasn't blitzer should tear your package
clean off
[Music]